good afternoon
thank you very much for coming to my
talk
so yes the title on the agenda is
automate yourself out of a job
with roslyn which gets people to come in
and then you find out that i'm not
actually going to teach you how to do
that so what i am going to teach and and
then the title that's on the slide is
write code that writes code with roslyn
and it's just occurred to me i've done
this talk a few times but it's just
occurred to me
that even that's not really accurate um
it's more write code that reads code
with roslyn
and then and then use that to write code
with c sharp
but anyway let's just dive in and
so before we kind of kick off too much
i'm going to put up
a visual studio
if you can't see the font if you can't
see the text
come this way a bit because i really i
can't make it much big if i make it much
bigger then the only thing you'll be
able to see is the words package
reference so we're not doing that
okay
i am mark rendall um i am a net
developer and uh i am the
creator and maintainer of visual recode
more about that later
i'm also
just brand new announced today a
developer advocate for a company called
polyscale so i have to mention that now
because if i mention that i can get them
to pay me for this hour
which is brilliant uh but polyscale if
you use um postgresql on mysql databases
uh on on the web on the cloud um it's
like cloudflare but via database
and so you can connect to your database
uh in an aws data center and that
database might be the other side of the
world in an azure data center but you're
still getting millisecond response times
it's super awesome and i'm very excited
about it
but that's not what this is about this
is about roslyn
and roslyn
the easiest way to describe it
these days is in visual studio
roslyn is the thing that looks at your
code and tells you you're an idiot
and you're doing it wrong
and and offers to fix it for you if you
press control dot
i should point out that if you have
resharper installed
then that's got nothing to do with
rosslyn at all resharper doesn't use
roslyn they have their own c sharp code
engine and so that's resharper that
tells you that you're an idiot and
offers to fix your code for you
but if you just have vanilla visual
studio or if you're using code rush code
rush also uses roslyn in increasingly
uh
no i'm not going to say that
what didn't he say
so yeah
i knew about roslyn but i hadn't really
done anything with it and then uh
microsoft
basically uh in
2018 2017 2018
when dot net call 3.1 came out and
scott hunter said the next version
of.net after dot net core 3.1 will not
be net core 4 it will be net 5 because
we're not having a net core 4 because
that's just too confusing even for us
even microsoft
didn't want that that confusing a
version number so they're only going to
go to net5
by the way if any of your api if any of
the stuff that you're using in the full
fat old fashioned net framework has not
been ported over to net core it's not
gonna be
and that included wcf
and
that made a lot of people very unhappy
and microsoft said hey if you're using
wcf then we recommend you go to grpc
we've got a brand new implementation of
grpc and it's brilliant
and people looked at their their
solution the average solution that
contains wcf has over a million lines of
code in it
now to be fair that's because the same
solution contains your wcf application
your windows forms application your wpf
application that you started to migrate
from windows forms but never finished
your web forms application your asp.net
mvc application the same thing as the
wpf and winforms applications and um in
in some cases that i have seen this year
some classic asp pages and it won't
build if you don't have visual basic six
installed
but there's some wcf code in there
the thing is though the wcf code
the code that's actually wcf is just
it's a service contract
and that's got some methods that call
into your business logic and then it's
got some data contracts and those are
the things that are used to send
messages backwards and forwards the bit
of the solution that is wcf
is actually very small
and i thought
i wonder if you could just write
something maybe using that roslyn thing
that i've heard about
that analyzes your
service contracts and your operation
contracts and your data contracts
and generates the grpc protobuf
equivalent
and so i tried that and yeah actually
that's really easy
and then i thought i wonder if i could
then also write code that maps
from the grpc service implementation
and just
calls into the old wcf service contract
implementation and handles all the
translation between the different data
contracts versus grpc messages and yeah
yeah turns out you can do that as well
and by that point i'd kind of managed to
teach myself roslyn reasonably well
because roslyn
is amazing
but what it isn't
is very well documented
um
so the best way to learn roslyn is uh
josh varti
has some blog posts which are incredibly
helpful but actually the the simplest
way is to dive into the open source
roslyn analyzers that microsoft have so
all those squiggly analyzers in visual
studio they're mostly open source
they're mostly built into roslyn rather
than visual studio and so i taught
myself um how to roslyn
uh using those code samples and i
thought well i'll try and kind of
summarize the the key points into a talk
and here we all are
so roslyn
um
if you don't know sort of what roslyn
actually is
up until sort of the early 2010s
the c-sharp compiler was written in c
plus and the vb.net compiler was written
in c plus plus
and
it was becoming extremely difficult to
maintain it and
one of the kind of uh
maturity
signals for any programming language is
is the compiler for that language
written in that language they call that
being self-hosted
and
nearly all languages are self-hosted
like the typescript compiler is written
in typescript for example and the
c-sharp compiler still wasn't written in
c sharp and so they went we're going to
rewrite it
in c-sharp
and that will make it work better in
visual studio which by then was a wpf
application
and
uh and we can do it so it'll be a
compiler as a service so we can package
up all the different bits of the
compiler the passer and
the
syntax trees and all that sort of thing
and we can distribute them on nougat and
so they rewrote the c-sharp compiler in
c-sharp yay and they rewrote the vb.net
compiler in vb.net which serves them
right
and they put it all up on nougat
and so all the roslin packages
most most of the roster packages start
with microsoft code analysis
am i hissing
why am i hissing
this noise okay
there we go that's better thank you very
much
now i'm going to go
just to wind him up
sorry mate thank you
so yes
uh and we've got uh
microsoft.codeanalysis.csharp.workspaces
and workspaces is is your kind of top
level thing so your workspace contains
your solution and your solution contains
your project and your projects contain
your documents and your documents
contain code
and so
the
thing that you nearly always need to
bring in before anything else is
microsoft.codeanalysis.com
and then
there's also
microsoft.codeanalysis.workspaces.various
things and there's an ms build
and there's an ad hoc
and there's a visual studio one but that
only works if you're working on a visual
studio extension
the ms build one is the most useful one
because that's the one where you can say
hey see that dot sln file there
open that and do your thing
and so that's what we're going to be
looking at today
we also have microsoft.build.locator
which
finds the right version of ms build that
is installed on your machine
so every time you install the net sdk
the modern.net sdk so net 6 or net core
3.1 you get a version of ms build
installed along with that sdk every time
you install visual studio you get two or
three versions of ms build installed
along with that and you also have the ms
build that is compiled using.net core or
net sex
and you have the ms build that is
compiled using net 4.7.2
and none of these things work together
and so what
microsoft.build.locator is supposed to
do is find the right one that's going to
work for your application so if you
include
microsoft.build.locator in a.net 6
application it will find the net 6
version of ms build if you put it in a
net framework application it will find
the net framework version
if it gets that wrong everything
explodes and your projects don't build
and nothing works
and then for reasons that i'm really not
entirely clear on you also need to bring
in new get.project model
just you just do
so
workspaces
go away mr insect that's my screen
workspaces are the top level thing and
you can essentially think of your
workspace as being like a virtual
invisible visual studio
um that's that's that kind of top level
container of all the things and
within your
so the types of workspace you have ad
hoc workspace
and this is one where you can just go
create an ad hoc workspace add a pretend
solution to it add a pretend project to
that solution add a pretend document to
that project
and you can muck about with it ad hoc
workspaces are fantastic for writing
unit tests and entirely and for sort of
messing about and experimenting and
entirely useless for anything else ms
build workspace is the one that you'll
be using the majority of the time unless
you are actually using the visual studio
sdk to write an extension in which case
you get the visual studio workspace
which is almost identical to the ms
build workspace
so your workspace has a solution and
your solution has a
one or more projects and your projects
have documents and not all of those
documents are c-sharp files they could
be
json files so your appsettings.json
that's the document
and so we have to check when we're going
through documents to make sure that they
are actually c-sharp documents
so for ms build we have to use
microsoft.build.locator
and
we install that package and then the
first thing we do
in our program and i mean literally
like class
program
main
ms build locator dot register defaults
don't let it do anything else at all
that's the first thing you do because
otherwise nine times out of ten it will
find the wrong one
and then you get your ms build workspace
and then you can start loading things
into it
so
let's jump over to the code quickly
and i will demonstrate that so here
we have our program.cs
and
we call ms build locator dot register
defaults
and then we create a workspace using ms
build workspace.create
and then we set a flag to say load
metadata for reference project equals
true that funnily enough is the thing
that needs that new get.project model
because referenced projects includes
nuget packages
so if you don't have that load metadata
for reference projects then it'll only
know about your source code it won't
know about and stuff that's in the
baseclasslibraryfor.net it won't know
about anything outside of that
then we add an event handler to
workspace failed because when the
compilation fails that's where it goes
because when we say var solution equals
await workspace.open solution async
that will always work it'll always give
you a solution back it's just that
solution might not have any projects in
it all those projects might not have any
documents in it because if a document
that's supposed to compile doesn't
compile it won't be in the project but
the only way you can know about that is
if you've added an event handler for
workspace failed
all of this
all of this i learned painfully
one thing at a time
sometimes in production
yes
so
the
unit of information in roslyn is the
syntax tree
and this is
an abstract representation
of your code
so we have a syntax tree a document if
it is a compilable document we'll be
able to give you a syntax tree
and
that syntax tree
contains syntax nodes and it's
essentially just like a dom
for your code so you have a root node
and then that has child nodes and each
of those nodes have child nodes and some
of these nodes will be things like a
declaration of a class
or a declaration of a property and some
of these nodes will be an opening brace
or a semicolon it goes right down to
that sort of level
and then we have tokens within that so a
token is something like an identifier
so a node might say i am a property
declaration syntax and within that node
there is a token which is the identifier
which is the name of the property
or it could be a semicolon
then we have syntax trivia
because we also have white space
and we have
commas in lists of attributes and we
have
comments and documentation comments
anything that the compiler doesn't
actually compile into
intermediate language is called trivia
and if you don't put trivia in
then all your code will be generated as
one great big long string and it'll be
completely unreadable like cobalt
there's a brilliant thing built into
visual studio has he got the thing
installed into visual studio he asks
himself
we go to view here
and we go to other windows
and syntax visualizer
very real chance you're not going to be
able to see this but
so
this is the
uh the best way to
learn about
what syntax trees look like and how they
relate to actual code so if you install
the visual studio sdk tools
and the
compiler tools as part of your visual
studio setup you can go in and modify it
and so forth one of the things it will
install for you is this syntax
visualizer and then you can click on
bits of your code
in your editor window here
and it will jump to that bit of code
over in the syntax tree
and so you can see here
if we go up to the top
we've got a using directive there
and that using directive consists of the
using keyword
and then it's got some white space after
it for
just that single space there and then it
has an identifier name which is an
identifier token which is system
and then it has the semicolon token
and
end of line trivia or new line trivia
okay and so you can go bouncing around
so if you wanted to say well i need to
find
the place in my code where somebody has
called
new sequel connection because i want to
check to see if they've called using
when they create their sequel connection
because i thought it might be a good
idea not to leak memory all over the
place
more on that at the party this evening
yeah you can essentially
look at the code that you want to be
able to find and in the syntax
visualizer you can click on it and then
you can
read through everything in there and
find out where that would actually be in
the abstract representation
that's literally all it's for
so that's a brilliant tool
um so just to restate it
if you go looking for that and it's not
there you need to install the sdk tools
and the compiler toolkit as part of your
visual studio setup
so
you've got your syntax tree loaded in
and there are
uh
two main ways that you can work with
that syntax tree and the simplest one is
that it has a link api so if you've used
link to xml where you say
element.elements and maybe give it a
name and then you can for reach through
those and you can do select and where
and of type and all this sort of stuff
and it's exactly the same with a roslin
syntax tree so i can say node.descendant
nodes dot of type class declaration
syntax and that if i do that from the
root of a document
it will go through and it will find all
instances of
public class or internal class
inside that document
ideally it will only find one because
you should only have one class
declaration syntax
in your application
however i have metrics
i have i have metrics that that show at
least one application that my tools been
used with that had one project that had
one document that had over 100 classes
all in the same document
and the person
when it did its thing and it copied
those classes over to a new solution it
split them all into separate so a class
file per class and the customer reported
that as a bug
welcome to my world
so yeah descendant nodes uh so that's
not the same as child knows there's a
child modes which goes get everything at
this level
descendant modes is all of them go down
through the entire tree and just find me
all the ones that are of the type class
declaration syntax
so
let's take a look at what this
looks like
so here we've got a syntax query demo
so we do this open solution here
and we go to list async
and we get our solution at the top level
there and we say for each
um
we're going to say
solution.projects.select many
and we're going to say um
project dot documents
and then we're going to say
await
document.getsyntax root async
we say if root is null continue because
that's if it doesn't return a syntax
root then it means either
the compiler wasn't able to make sense
of that for reasons probably to do with
it having loaded the wrong ms build
or
it's not a c-sharp document or a vb
document if it's neither of those two
things won't work with f sharp there's
no rosalind for f-sharp that's a whole
different set of tools and i don't know
them
and then we can say for each type
declaration syntax in root dot
descendant nodes dot of type
base type
declaration
syntax
so class declaration syntax and struct
declaration syntax and interface
declaration syntax and enum
and delegate
and
have i forgotten anything in c sharp
that types at the top
level oh record now yes
see that's i don't forgotten that i'm
just still living in 2018.
um
so yes that will find all of those uh
all the things that come from that
and then from there
we can get the name space declaration
syntax so we can go navigate back up the
tree by saying first ancestor or self
and so go back up the tree until we find
something that is a namespace
declaration syntax
and then from the type declaration
syntax we can get the identifier.txt
which is just the name of the type
and from the namespace declaration
syntax might not have found one might be
the root file might just be the
program.cs from a net 6 application in
which case it won't find a program class
because
weird things are happening there and
don't get me started
but if it does find it then it'll give
you that there and then it'll do
console.writeline namespacename.typename
and so if i switch over to
my powershell here and i make that a bit
bigger
there we go
and i do net run
and it embarrasses me by oh no it
doesn't
next time when i've changed it and it
has to build that it'll tell me i've
done something wrong and i don't care
so we can see here that we've got a
sample.program and a
sample.library.greater
thank you very much good night
uh no
so that is one way
to
to navigate through
your syntax tree using roslyn
but that's um
it can get quite hairy sort of writing
all those queries and where clauses and
and whatever else and also it's not the
most efficient
approach to doing this
and
one of the things that you can do with
roslyn that we'll look at at the end of
the talk is you can create your own
visual studio analyzers and code fixes
and when you're doing that
essentially your analyzer is running
kind of like every keystroke and so you
want it to be fast and the link api is
not the fast way of doing this so this
is great for something that's
sort of analyzing code on check-in or
rewriting wcf as grpc or whatever it
might be
but
if you want something that's a little
bit more
performant and easier to work with
then there is the c-sharp syntax walker
so this is the visitor pattern
except i hate calling it that because
there's another class called c-sharp
syntax visitor and you don't want to use
that one you want to use c-sharp syntax
walker
c-sharp syntax walker
you
give it a syntax node like the root
syntax node from the document and you
say there you go
visit that and what you're actually
saying is walk that and it will go
through all the nodes and then it will
call
visit class declaration every time it
finds a class declaration syntax mode
and it will call visit interface
declaration and so forth that is the
visitor pattern
c sharp syntax visitor will only walk
to one level
um as soon as it hits something it'll go
i found it and now i'm stopping
which
isn't really the visitor pattern as i
understand it so the one that you want
is c-sharp syntax walker and so we have
a demonstration of c-sharp syntax walker
and
for some reason
we've used
syntax visitor
i'm going to rename that just because
that's terrible
there we go syntax walker demo much
better
right
so in here we create a new list types
walker
and then we have our for reach through
our documents and and everything else
and then we call this walker dot visit
and if i go to my list types walker
you can see here
that we have visit class declaration
and visit interface declaration and then
we have this write method down here that
essentially does the same thing
as the
link code was doing
the important thing here
is that
when i override these methods
i have to call that base method
if i don't call that base method then it
stops
so if there's a class declaration nested
inside my class declaration it won't
find it so what that base method does is
essentially say and continue walking
so and this is this is one of those
things where i thought i should do a
talk because
that's not intuitive
and
um
if you go on to microsoft docs and you
look at the documentation for visit
class declaration it says visits a class
declaration
and that's it
and seriously it's it's they
um i love the ruslin team they've built
something amazing and i wouldn't have
been able to do a bunch of the stuff
that i've done without them and i
wouldn't be here giving this talk but
they use bloody ghost stock to generate
their documentation
and yeah
so you have to call that base method
um and this is this is fantastic because
this essentially let's just do a control
shift s
and
so if i go out to here and do dot net
run
there we go got some build warnings
and exactly the same thing happens um
and it took seven seconds but that
included the build um
so yeah exactly the same thing you just
have to trust me when i say that it used
less memory
and less cpu to do that and therefore it
is better
okay
so
we can walk syntax and
you can literally just kind of do uh
use intellisense and you can see
um if you put syntax it'll just show you
all the types that end in syntax which
is basically everything um i actually
learned i can't remember what it was but
i distinctly remember i learned that a
c-sharp feature existed
because i saw syntax for it when i was
working with roslyn and i was kind of
like what the hell is that
um and
yeah that's you know it was um
it's everything is in there record
syntax and all this sort of stuff
but
it's really difficult to make sense of
what all that syntax means by yourself
so for example
let's say
that
i see
the word string although there's a type
string
now is that
it's got a capital s
so
it's possible that someone's just
written capital s string instead of the
keyword string in which case i should be
writing an analyzer that fixes that for
them because you shouldn't do it the
keyword string though shows up as the
same type as if you had system.string
but could it be
that i'm actually going through the wcf
application for a company that
manufactures distributes and sells
string
possibly
so how do i know if this string is so
and this is up at the top of the class
there i've got um using system
but i might also have using
stringcode.stockcontrol.models
and there might be something else and i
don't want to have to bounce around all
over the place trying to work out from
the syntax whether we're talking about a
string of characters
or string for tying up your christmas
presents
i had a conversation with my wife once i
was just going oh just the string
handling's so bad
and she just she looked at me and she
went the what
and i went the string handling in this
application it's terrible and she went
why is the application handling string
and it occurred to me that
to the kinds of people that we're not
that's not what string means
you know which makes it even more
terrifying that when i go on to google
and search for string
it takes me to the microsoft
documentation and not amazon
and i know that's terrifying because i'm
trying using duckduckgo for a month and
when i put string in go it takes me to
amazon
so anyway making sense of what these
syntax tokens and nodes and everything
actually means is where semantic models
comes in
so the semantic model
is
the combination of the syntax tree
and the in-memory compilation of the
code
and so
there is a semantic model and for every
point in the syntax tree you can go give
me the bit of the semantic model
that is what this syntax means
and that is where roslin gets really
clever because that is where you can go
okay
i have a type here
give me this type information and then i
can say is this system.string or
stringcode.stock.string
and so semantic models
uh
you don't compile documents obviously in
c
you compile projects
and so we create a compilation by saying
await project dot get compilation async
we will always get something back off
that it may just be full of errors so
this this tends to work best with code
that does compile but it'll give it a
good try with code that doesn't
and then we can get a semantic model
from that by saying a weight
compilation.getsemantic model that
should say async sorry um from the
semantic tree which we've got from our
document so our document goes here is
all the code represented as a syntax
tree and then we throw that to the
compilation and we go give me the
semantic model for this syntax tree and
it gives us back our model
and within that model
where in the syntax tree we have nodes
and the nodes have tokens and
identifiers and trivia the semantic
model has symbols
and so
let's say i've got my
from this test application that i got
here i've got a greeter and that's a
class declaration syntax
um that is called greeter and so i can
get the symbol info from that by saying
model dot get symbol info and passing in
that identifier name syntax and then
that will give me
an ie named type symbol in this
particular instance and then i can get
all the information about that from
from that semantic model and this works
with
everything so an awful lot of stuff that
comes through in c-sharp is an
expression syntax
so x equals 42 is an expression syntax
that's an assignment expression but it
has a return value
i plus plus is an expression syntax it's
a unary expression but it has a return
value
and i can get the type
of that expression which is insanely
useful because it means that i can do i
can sort of work out if i look at a
method and then i look at all the
expressions in that method then i can
find all the types that that method
needs to work
which is super helpful
so
let me just go back to here and we'll
just check
um
so here's my symbol demo
and so we're going to say
go through each project and for each
project get the compilation and if the
compilation is null continue
so i said compilation will always return
something it won't necessarily always
return something because
one of the types of project in a
solution is a solution folder and so you
might have a solution folder that's just
got like your docker files and your
readme.txt and so if you call get
compilation async on a solution folder
project you'll get null back and then we
go for each one of those
of the documents in that project get its
syntax tree and if it hasn't got a
syntax tree then carry on
then get its semantic model
then we get the root out of that tree
and then we can say for each type
declaration syntax in root descendant
nodes dot of type get our base type
declaration syntax
then we can say get the declared symbol
for this type declaration syntax that
should always return an i named type
symbol but sometimes it will return an i
error type symbol which says it's there
i kind of know about it but i can't make
sense of it
and then we can write our type kind
which is class or interface or struct or
enum
and then
with now we have that thing about we
don't have to go find ancestor node
namespace declaration because this i
named type symbol
once you get to the point of working
with this it's really nice because it
looks almost exactly like type from the
net framework itself it's just you're
doing it at design time with the code
rather than at runtime with
object.gettype
but it's pretty much
it maps
directly even if it doesn't use the same
words for everything so our symbol.
containing namespace and symbol.name and
then we can say
symbol.getmembers.of type method symbol
so there's no get methods
um or get properties or get fields it's
just get members and then you can say of
type i method symbol
or once you get fed up with doing that
you can write three extension methods
called get properties get fields and get
methods
and then
uh for
um
for that method symbol we can say is
implicitly declared and if it's not we
can write out the symbol name like that
so now if we run that again
so yeah
so because we have a class called
sample.program and that has a method
main and a method ask name and we have a
class sample.library.greater
and that has a method called dotsetor
which is the constructor
and it has a
method called greet
that is implicitly declared
that's kind of important because
uh
a lot of these classes have implicitly
declared methods they all have an
implicitly declared static constructor
that does nothing if you haven't
specified a parameter list constructor
it will have an implicitly declared
parameter list constructor unless it's a
static class
because all classes have to have a
constructor
if you've got properties on there then
it will have implicitly declared get and
set methods for those properties
and if god help you you've got an async
method on there
it will have
like warren piece of of implicitly
declared types and methods and fields
and state machines and lord knows what
else so basically that um on all these
symbols there's an is implicitly
declared method that basically says did
i write this or did the c-sharp compiler
write this because if the c-sharp
compiler wrote it i don't care i don't
want to know about it just keep it away
from me
just
it's a brilliant website that i use a
lot called sharplab.io
and you type in some c sharp code and on
the right hand side it will show you
the c sharp code that the c-sharp
compiler generates for the c-sharp code
that you wrote which includes things
like async state machines and then it
will show you the il code that's
generated and then if you give it a
target platform it will show you the
machine code that it generates for like
windows x64 or linux x64
so yeah
so we found all the methods but we can
use this to find all the used types in
this entire solution by looking at the
expressions within those methods
so if we go back to here
and
we're going to use
oh no we've got a symbol visitor
which i tend to skip over
so we have a list types visitor here so
in the same way that there is a c-sharp
syntax walker there is a symbol visitor
i'm going to mention it because it's
there
and
if you know it's there then you might
sort of go and explore it and you might
use it and if you use it you might find
out what it's for and if you do can you
please email me and tell me
but it's there it's it's another way
that you can go through all the types so
this will actually let you go through
all the types in a solution this symbol
all the symbols in a model without
worrying about the syntax tree at all
and i have never found a a useful use
case for that because it's the syntax
that you kind of really care about it's
not the symbols the symbols give you
information about the syntax but never
mind
so so that is there but i'm going to
skip over it because um
it it takes time but finding all used
types so if we go back to here
and we can go into the dependencies demo
and we can go into list
all used types
like this
so
i'm going to pass in a solution
and
we're going to
we're going to create a new set of types
which is just going to be a hash set of
string which is going to make sure that
we don't list the same type twice i'm
going to go through each of our projects
we're going to get a compilation
make sure we've got a compilation and
then we're going to go through our
documents
in our projects and
then we're going to do another thing
we're going to say if document dot is
auto generated
and this
has become even more important recently
and i need
to update this probably
in the same way that your
your classes have
implicitly declared uh fields and
methods and that sort of thing your
project has implicitly declared or
generated documents
so for every xaml file in the wpf
application there's a generated dot g
dot cs or xaml.cs for that xaml file
um
these tend to have designer dot
generated dot g or dot gi in the file
name but not reliably so
and this is just the ones that microsoft
have done by the way never mind sort of
third-party things
also if you've got source generators in
there then
those throw stuff in and one of the
things that they say in source
generators which is not in this talk but
i'm writing a whole other talk about
source generators
is that you should put dot g dot cs as
the file name for the generated source
or sometimes you get temporary generated
file underscore that goes in there as
well
and then we also have this begins with
auto-generated
comment and this is quite useful so we
can say if we've got this root syntax
node if it has leading trivia
then let's go through the leading trivia
and find if it's a multi-line comment so
that's a comment that starts with
slash asterisk and ends with asterisk
slash because
one of the nice things that everybody
always does when they auto generate a
file is put a multi-line comment at the
top of the file saying this file was
generated by a tool
as opposed to some of the stuff in
source control which would say
this code was written by a tool
so yes and then we can look there and we
can just see if it's got the words auto
generated or auto dash generated this
catches
honestly probably about 50
of generated code but it's better than
nothing
one of the things it does catch in net
core or net five six applications is the
auto generated assembly info.cs file um
that goes in there now because that's
now auto generated from cs proj
but that does have the leading comments
although i believe it is still just
called assemblyinfo.cs
so in our dependencies
demo here
we say if it's an auto generated
document just crack on because i don't
care about that
then we're going to say you get the
syntax tree from this
and
if that's null then we can continue on
then we'll say get the semantic model
for that
and then we can say get the root
uh syntax node from that tree check for
that auto generated comment at the start
and then we have this get types method
here and we're going to pass in our
route
and our model
and here we're going to properly get our
link on
so we're going to say descendant nodes
dot of type identifier name syntax
and then we're going to say model dot
get symbol info in there and then of
type i named uh type symbol so
identifier name syntax is a
variable name which could be in a method
or it's a field declaration or a
property declaration or a parameter
declaration in a method this will find
all of those
and then we get the symbol info for that
identifier which will tell us what kind
of
identifier that is and then for the ones
where it is a known type then that will
be an i named type symbol so that gets
us all our variables our parameters and
all those sorts of things
and then we can do the same thing again
except this time we're looking for
expression syntax and so this gets us
things like
you may
somebody might have called a method
and passed in
1024 as an expression because they
couldn't be bothered to do the maths to
work out how many bytes there are in a
megabyte um and so expression syntax
will find
1024 times 1024
and the type of that will just be int
and so we get a named types that are
from our identifiers and our expression
types that are from expressions within
the code and then we push them all into
one innumerable here
name types and expression types and then
we call distinct on that
and distinct
those yellow lines that keep coming out
when i do that run thing
is
symbol
equality comparer
dot default
and now that
isn't going to build at all
because
it won't let you do that
named type symbol equality comparer dot
instance
so yeah
i use name type symbol equality
comparer.instance and they still get the
warning saying use symbol equality
comparer when comparing symbols i am
it bothers me
that that's an analyzer
written by the person who wrote the
thing that writes the analyzers
and it's
quite clearly telling me something
wrong
anyway let's just do a save on this
and then we can
come back out to here and we can do a
net run again
and it takes it a while
but yes
so it started off with the main
application and the first thing it found
in there that was used was
system.library.greater
because it creates an instance of
greeter but it's also found usages of
system.boolean child console in 32
string and
void
void is a type
and
it's
i always always forget that but the
return type of a void method is not
it's system.void
and
you know you messed up when your
protobuf generator
um
you sort of didn't write the tests
properly and you release a new version
of your project and then someone comes
back and goes my protobuf compiler is
giving me errors saying system.void is
not a known protobuf type and you're
kind of like
[__]
maybe roll back to the previous version
while i fix that
so yeah system.void is a type
okay
so now we can understand code we can
read code we can look at code we can go
hunting for patterns within code we can
write link queries and we can write
walkers not visitors walkers
against our code so now we get to the
interesting bit can we rewrite code
and
you're not going to automate yourself
out of a job by doing this by the way
but what you can do
sometimes
is
let's say you're upgrading to a new
version of a
nuget package
or
a new version of net
and there's a better way of doing
something now
and
your team lead or or somebody who hates
you says can you go through all the code
and
change
all of these things to use this new way
of doing something
or more
likely
can you go through the code and change
them
to
do this
the company approved way of doing
something
because
you know if it's like can you go through
some people don't like the var keyword
because it makes code reviews difficult
and it's kind of like if you find that
makes code reviews difficult personally
i don't want you reviewing my code but
never mind
um
so somebody might say oh just we never
used the var keyword never ever ever
now that's actually quite easy to fix
you can sort of all enter with resharper
and just say go through the entire
solution and just replace var with the
actual type of whatever it is
as if your manager doesn't know about
resharper then you can take the rest of
the week off just make sure you commit
it
kind of a few files at a time and
write a python script to do pushes every
2.43 hours
and go to the beach
hire me
this people go oh do talks for exposure
and it's kind of like yeah no really i
can't i know
so yeah we want to rewrite code but yes
you can use this to automate incredibly
boring um bits of code but it becomes
interesting it's it's challenging
because one of the things with roslyn
is
everything in there is immutable
so the thing that you can change is the
syntax tree
and
but you can't
change
a syntax node you can only replace it
with another syntax node
and
[Music]
when you replace that
syntax node in a syntax tree
it essentially invalidates that entire
syntax tree right the way up to the root
node there is now a completely new
syntax tree
with that new node in it
and the old one is dead and
uh and you you've broken it
so the syntax tree is immutable
so you think all right well i'll just go
to the document and i'll set the
documents new syntax set document syntax
tree equals this new syntax tree where
i've done this thing documents immutable
as well
so
now you have to go back to the project
and say hey project replace this
document here with this new version with
the syntax tree that i updated because i
added
a new line character
somewhere in the source code
um except it turns out project is
immutable as well
i say all right so i go to the solution
and say no no no solution that's
immutable as well
so
the point at which it stops being
immutable is the
workspace
and so what you do is you change your
syntax node all the way down in the code
over here and then you come back all the
way up to the top here and you go
work workspace dot apply changes
and then workspace dot save and it'll
write everything out that changed
which is lots of fun
you think about doing that
let's say
well let's just use the example i'm
about to show here i want to go through
this is more like an april fools joke
that you might play on somebody
i want to go through
every string instance
anywhere in this entire solution whether
it's a literal string or the returned
value from a method or a property or
whatever it might be and i just want to
add two upper invariant on the end of it
that's the kind of nice version the
nasty version would be to add a dot
replace
the time i hacked my wife's microsoft
word to replace any references to
margaret thatcher with that [__]
would probably be okay but she worked
for
margaret thatcher
okay so yes what things in rosalind are
immutable everything solutions projects
um documents syntax so you think if
you've got like a thousand line class
and you want to go through and replace
every syntax node in there that is a
string with a new syntax node that is
basically that syntax node but now with
dot to upper invariant tacked onto the
end of it
and that
so i've changed one so now i've got to
go i'll go back up to here and i'll
start again and
then now i've now i changed is hang on
no i've just changed the same one and
now it says dot 2 upper invariant dot to
upper invariant because it is at least
deterministic and i'm hitting the same
string expression every time
um
how do i keep track of which so
unfortunately
um the the team realized this and so
they gave a c-sharp syntax rewriter
and this is almost exactly like c-sharp
syntax walker
except instead of returning void or
system.void these methods return a
syntax node so they look at the syntax
node and they say do i need to change
you and if i do here's a new syntax node
with those changes and i'll return that
and if i don't i'll just return the node
as it was passed in and this
lets us
take care
of
all those nastiness is
around immutable code
so let us
close all but this
and we will go to here and here
and we will go into rewrite a demo dot
up shift all strings
so
go through all the projects get the
compilation do the blah blah blah blah
make sure it's not auto generated
because we don't want to do that get the
semantic model now we have
an a new string literal up shifter
and so
this
is a c sharp syntax rewriter but we're
going to pass in our semantic model
so that we can use that to make sure
that we're up shifting
text and not balls of string from
stringcode's stock control system
and we just have visit literal
expression this is one of the things
that we can override in here so we're
only going to find the hard-coded
strings with quote quote around them
we're not going to do this on everything
so visit literal expression
we can say if
model dot get type info of node.type is
i name type symbol type
if type name equals string
now
i could stop there
because
if it's a literal expression and it's a
string it's system.string because you
can't have literal expressions for
anything else
but
c sharp 12 maybe possibly c sharp 30 you
know it might be c sharp 27. at some
point they're going to put utf-8 string
literals into c-sharp
and then to upper invariant might not be
available because what does to upper
invariant mean on a string that consists
entirely of emoji because it's an elon
musk business tweet
so let's just belton braces as we say in
britain we'll make double sure
we'll just say
give me the members of this
and make sure it's got
string dot two upper invariant in it
make sure it's got that method because i
don't want to i don't want my april
fool's joke to result in my
friend's um
program not compiling because then he
might not deploy it into production and
hilarity might not ensue
okay
so then in here
we can now use a syntax factory
and so this is where we write code that
writes code
so we can say
create a an invocation expression so
that's essentially a call a method call
so we're going to invoke and then we
have a member access expression
to say
uh we are accessing a member on a on
this field
and then we have our syntax kind is
simple member access expression so
string dot two upper invariant that dot
that's a simple member access expression
and then the node which is whatever that
string literal was in the first place
and then on the end of that we're going
to add syntax factory dot identifier
name name of string.2 upper invariant
now
the other thing i could do in here
is i could get the text of that node
and i could
put it in a string
and to the end of that string i could
concatenate dot to upper invariant
open parens close parens and then i
could use syntaxfactory.pass
to turn that into a syntax node that
works just as well
and in an awful lot of cases that is the
easier way to do these things i'm just
using this to kind of demonstrate i'll
show you an example of the syntax
factory.pass later
there are people who say if you are
generating c sharp code you should do it
like this
with roslyn
to make sure that you are generating
c-sharp code correctly
i am not one of those people for the
most part i say if you are generating
c-sharp code generating it not
modifying it if you're generating an
entire c sharp file
for for whatever reason
then just use a string builder
use an indented string builder for sure
but use a string builder because this
it's really invocation expressions and
member access expressions and all this
sort of stuff and that is literally
we're just going add dot to upper
invariant to the end of whatever's
already there
so yes but you you can do this like this
so
um we
if
uh
we this
if the type is type and if the thing is
string then we are returning this so
we're returning our brand new syntax
node that includes our old syntax node
and then c sharp syntax rewriter is
going to take care
of working out which node it passed in
and which node has come back out
and then at the end of this whole
process when it's visited all the nodes
in this tree
it will call replace nodes and pass in a
bunch of tuples saying replace this node
with this node and this node with this
node and this node with this node
and you will get
something out where a whole bunch of
nodes have been replaced
and then we can say so we say new root
equals up shifter dot visit root
and then syntax
nodes have a dot is equivalent to
and dot is equivalent to basically says
is this syntax tree equivalent to this
syntax tree
annoyingly
that will return false if you've added
some white space or other things that
don't bloody matter you can hack around
that but
i'm not going to here
but if it's not equivalent then we
literally say new solution equals new
solution dot with document syntax root
and we pass in the document id here and
we pass in our new root
and it finds where that document id is
in the existing solution and it replaces
that document in that project with this
new document with our new syntax route
and so that is how you work with the
immutability in roslyn
it's fun right
it is
for me
the really great thing about this
is it means that writing visual recode
is hard
and
so it puts other people off from doing
it that's really what i'm doing here is
i'm going look you can do this but it's
so difficult please don't
god i sound lucky
eddie murphy when i laugh
or possibly stampy
anyone's kids watch stampy long nose on
youtube
are you lucky
okay
so when we get to the top and we can say
have we done have we made any changes
because there's it's a chance that there
are no string literals anywhere in this
thing and if there aren't then we don't
undo this but um and we say
workspace.try apply changes and we pass
the new solution in one of the nice
things that will happen at this point is
that if anything else on and say another
thread
has changed the solution
since
the solution that we based this on so if
you've got like a conflicting thing
then it will try and apply the changes
from this new solution and do a sort of
git merge in memory but if somebody else
has changed it it'll just go no sorry
yours is out of date i can't make sense
of it you changed the same documents
that they changed that's not going to
fly for me
go back around to the top and
essentially do it again and hope that
eventually
nothing else on any other threads is
going to do nasty things
so
if we go over to code here
um
and we just go
bang bang bang bang bang
so we got our greeter here
which is going to return hello
underscore name and we've got
what's your name here
this is essentially
the c-sharp version of the very first
program i ever wrote on a sinclair zx81
in 1982
um but yeah
it's also the first
program that i showed my daughter how to
write
and she's now building games with unity
so that's fun
so yeah if i go back to here
and
we go into programs that we're on
up shift all strings
and we do dotnet run
one change is applied
that's interesting there were two
strings mark your demos broken it hasn't
worked no it has
so yeah there you go console.rightline
what's your name dot to upper invariant
uh
so it found that string literal and it
replaced it
and then in greeter.cs
and
i have honestly i've done this on
purpose because this caught me
again with released software
dollar
hello underscore name is not a string
literal expression
it's an invocation because it's actually
underneath it's being turned into an
interpolation
method and a call to string dot format
or whatever it is so yeah
if you wanted to stick dot to upper
invariant on the end of that you would
have to be catching that separately and
i'm not going to tell you how you can do
that as an exercise if you've ever
actually used anything you've learned in
this workshop
okay
so um
there are uses for this around change
all the way we do this in the entire
solution and i expect it to take you six
weeks aha
one half day right roslin thing start it
running
set get thing go to beach um
but the thing where it's really useful
is
uh
for writing analyzers that's the place
where you can most easily put it in and
roslyn analyzers
can be used in
uh
in two different contexts so you can
publish them as a visual studio
extension
and then they'll run on anything that's
opened in that instance of visual studio
but you can
it's the end times run
you can also publish them as new get
packages and then when someone installs
your new get package the analyzer
becomes active just in that project that
they've got that installed in so
for example if you use x unit for
testing
um x unit puts squiggles so if you use
theory and inline data
and the number of things in the inline
data attribute don't match the number of
parameters to the method that's the x
unit roslin analyzer that's noticing
that for you
so they're super useful for that they're
super useful if you've got a shared
library that you're using throughout
your organization then you can put in
analyzers to make sure that people are
using that properly as well
so
they and i have worked
at
companies that have internal nuget
packages and it became a best practice
to
sort of put a roslin analyzer alongside
your
library package just to make sure that
people were using it correctly or to
make it easier for them to use it
and one example of this was
i was working for a bank and i went
through and i added
system.diagnostics.diagnostic source all
the way through this wpf application
and they went this is great and we want
more of this and we want everybody to be
able to
use this
and
so this code sample here is wrong
okay because this is just saying i've
got this diagnostics field here and that
set something and i'm just going to call
diagnostics.right
which means
i'm going to
create this object here this new a
equals 42
every time we come through here
even if nothing's listening on that
diagnostics listener so if there's
nothing at the other end i'm still
creating an object that's coming through
here and
we had this in stuff that was running a
hundred times a second because this was
a trading system and it was just going
bang bang bang bang bang get the stock
update get the stock update get the
stock update and so what you're supposed
to do
is say
if diagnostic stock is enabled then do
the diagnostics.right
so
you don't incur the overhead and this
was really important because we wanted
to put this everywhere in the
application
but we only wanted it active
if we turned the listener on with a line
in config
on a particular desktop machine we did
not want that overhead of creating
objects and doing measuring and
everything else
sorry
five minutes
yeah
are we supposed to have finished
i thought we finished at 3 20.
[__] me i talk
i am so sorry
i thought we still
anyway
go i am i am so so sorry um
there there's a diagnostic source
analyzer
oh
i am the worst person in the entire
world um what i'll do is i'll tweet that
with the ndc portal hashtag and you can
go and look at it and maybe you can
refine me and ask about it
honestly i've been looking at my watch
been quite happily looking at my watch
going i've got five minutes i'm really
really sorry um go and grab coffee and
do the things and and have fun and um
yeah i'll be back in here in an hour
doing the.net rocks live and i'll do
stuff at the party and everything thank
you very much for coming sorry for
running over and i'll see you again
[__]